à l'issue de cette assise et de ce lundi
21 septembre 2020 le collège a désigné
des personnalités ci-après en qualité de
président et vice président de la
transition pour assurer la mise en
oeuvre de la feuille de route de la
transition président de la transition au
mali michel bentot vice président de la
transition que l'on assimile brut à la
cérémonie de prestation de serment aura
lieu le vendredi 25 septembre 2020 bon
j'aurais voulu qu'on soit ici en
politique parce que le mali est en
démocratie bientôt 25 ans je pense qu'il
ya des acteurs majeurs selon l'avis gens
qui ont l'expérience et qui ont vraiment
la rigueur pour conduire cette
transition
mais c'est un dommage qu'on a constaté
un show très contente parce que il est
purement politique
c'est pourquoi je suis très content ces
militaires des car elle aussi il a été
maintes fois est un major de l'armée de
l'air et il a occupé des gars on pense
au sein de l'armée des fêtes qu'il a
étudiée a réussi et ça nous ouvre la
voie vers la russie aussi je pense qu'il
n'a pas fondamentalement d'hommes de la
situation dans le pays a les hommes qui
peuvent faire les choses il ya des
personnalités qui sont moins clivante je
crois qu'il fait partie des
personnalités qui sont les moins que les
ventes du pays mais véritablement la
situation ne peut être résolue qu'à
travers un sursaut national donc ce ne
sera pas le président de la transition
lui seul mais l'ensemble des acteurs
malien politiques civiles et militaires
qui conduira à bon terme cette
transition